être jugé par ses pairs c'est un droit
fondamental dont peut se prévaloir d'un
accusé devant la cour supérieure son
devoir qui est lourd de responsabilités
la durée et en cette semaine
d'appréciation du jury au canada on va
s'entretenir avec la sénatrice lucie
mention qui a présenté une motion au
sénat en faveur de cet événement à la
mention bonjour
bonjour alors vous avez vous même été
juré c'est dans un procès pour meurtre
au premier degré il y a trente ans
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus marqué de
cette expérience
c'est ce que c'est ce que l'on est on
hérite donc de
grès de d'une situation comme celle là
pendant la durée du procès on est si
vous voulez
devant des photos de vendée en mouvement
toutes sortes de choses qui sont quand
même assez difficile à voir vous arrivez
là dedans vous êtes reconnaissants du
tout du milieu juridique vous ne
connaissez pas le fonctionnement de la
cour vous vous retrouvez devant des
pièces à conviction qui sont assez
intimidante je vous dire on vous
présente des photos des vidéos des
choses qui sont assez difficiles à voir
et
ensuite on vous indique que vous ne
pouvez pas parler de ce que vous voyez
de ce que vous entendez
donc sacrés si vous voulez cette espèce
de de culture de silence et lorsqu'on
quitte à la fin du procès le juge nous
indique que l'on ne peut parler de ce
qui s'est passé dans les débats dans les
délibérations
ce qui fait que on part avec ce bagage
de je vous dirais d'horreur parce que
dans la grande partie c'est ce qu'il
nous reste et on ne peut pas en parler à
personne et salah des effets pervers je
voudrais sur notre comportement dans les
mois qui suivent la fin d'un procès
quelles ont été les conséquences pour
vous justement dans les mois qui ont
suivi
avant que je comprenne l'origine
c'était des colère c'était des colères
qui se manifester
de façon très spontanée
et c'était elle était de plus en plus
récurrente jusqu'à ce que un jour mon
mari me disent j'ai pas besoin d'aller
de faire soigner et j'ai été sous le
choc à ce moment là puis j'y suis allé
je suis allé me faire soigner
ça m'a aidé ça moi il est beaucoup
et lorsque j'ai compris l'origine du
problème je vous dirais que ça à régler
la situation
beaucoup ce que ça laisse par contre ce
n'est plus de la colère mais je vous
dirais que c'est une grande tristesse
et je deviens émotive facilement si je
reparle de ce procédé
dans certaines situations ouais ouais un
procès comme ça on peut l'imaginer donne
accès à des
non seulement des images mais même à des
concepts à des idées auxquelles peu de
gens ont accès dans la société en
général
de quelle façon vous pensez que les
jurés pourraient être mieux préparés
mieux encadrer pour cette page là
nous on recommande si vous voulez un
accès à d'autres services 1 lorsque les
gens ont terminé leur travail de jury
c'est de pouvoir participer à des
sessions de débreffage on a fait des
sondages auprès d'anciens membres de
jury et les gens comme ça retourner chez
eux tous disaient qu'ils se sentaient
ceux qui se sentaient isolés des autres
qu'il se sentait à part vous avez de la
difficulté à revenir à leur vie normale
parce qu'il parce que les gens autour
d'eux ne comprenais pas ce qui s'était
passé les gens banalisent et le fait
qu'ils avaient été jury dont les séances
de dépressage de l'accès à des services
de thérapie ou des coûte 24 heures
par jour 7 jours par semaine lorsque les
membres de jury en ont besoin pour
discuter de certaines choses ou pour
passer une émotion
ou tout simplement pour comprendre ce
qui se passe dans de
niort aussi de préparer les gens qui
entourent les membres des jurés à être
en mesure de leur aider au moment où ils
sont dans les sons sont en train de
délibérer ou pendant les procès il ya
toute la question de la compensation
aussi les compensations financières et
beaucoup d'employeurs qui ne payent pas
leurs employés lorsqu'ils sont appelés à
être jury donc on demande aux provinces
de regarder
d'évaluer des façons de corriger cette
situation non une dizaine de situations
comme celle là qui sont énumérées si
vous voulez dans notre sens il propose
si on confère au gouvernement des
propositions importantes effectivement
parce que la question de la rémunération
elle revient souvent l'indemnité
présentement québec 63 dollars par jour
de la ok ça commence à devenir
journaliers alors pour bien les jurys
effectivement ça peut représenter une
pression supplémentaire madame lucie
mention merci d'avoir été avec nous cet
après midi thiam a fait plaisir au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit